have you have you ever been working up
to the deadline where you've been
working on the show and
it's it's it's been airing like the next
day yeah
well it was for hiroka oh uh it was i
think uh
uh season three i was doing my genga so
yeah gengar is the second step of the
key animation
and uh what what does gengar involve
okay okay so
okay okay knows nothing about animation
so we're gonna break it down
for now i will explain the process of
the fabrication of genga
okay so you have the key animator me and
i'm i receive an offer of work by
twitter or by mail
or twitter sometime twitter because a
lot of
assistant production are looking for
animators on twitter
and so for japan most of the japanese
animators they use twitter has a
portfolio or contacts tons of yeah
right and so
hi i'm i'm from this studio i have this
project
uh the schedule is that do you want to
work on it
so i look my schedule if it's okay if
it's a good match
yeah sure okay so let's put a
date for me do the meetings so okay this
date
so i go to the schedule meet
the director episode and assistant
production who i
send mails and we are doing the the
meeting
for the sequence i have choose at first
they send me a storyboard a storyboard
is
uh a little comic technical comic
about like a rough outline of how it
seems
with the camera works technical notes
right right
and i choose my sequence a sequence can
be just
like three cut 30 cuts 19 cuts
what what's a cut i cut it to one
yeah so you know when in in live action
when you film something and then the
camera cuts right right obviously
in animation you don't have an entire
scene that you cut out of that's
pre-planned
right right that makes sense and so one
shin can be one second or 10 seconds
30 seconds it depends and if there is a
lot of
seconds let's say more works right right
naturally and so
let's take an example okay i will choose
this sequence it's 10 cut
and so i go to the meeting so meeting
for with the
director and he's going to explain me
how he see uh how he want
those 10 cuts make okay right and he
expect me yeah for this cut
i would like a a rough animation a more
action
like a form of west coast or we said uh
sakuga sakura guys
sakura is like the western slang word
like certainly yeah yeah yeah so the
word
sakuga in western world
is completely different to what sakura
in japanese actually is
yeah so in so in the anime community we
refer to sakuga as good animation right
yeah like lots of frames lots of flashy
animation but in japanese sakuga just
means
frames yeah yeah if you only you look at
the kanji saku make
so it's kind of become like a buzz word
here right right yeah
sounds makes sense like uh if you say
anime in japan
animation yeah but if you say anime in
uh west
it's mean it's only japanese japanese
animals so in japan monsters inc is
technically an anime yes
hello my anime list hello hello
so you had like 10 cuts of my hero
academia to do
yeah and different types of animation uh
different types of animation sometimes
just talkings yeah little actings
and sometimes some action kits and so
i do the meeting with the director so it
takes like 30 minutes
after so i have to do the first step
it's the layout
yeah so i'm going to explain what it is
okay okay
you're telling me words and i have no
idea tell me what the layout
layout is so you have the storyboard i
i see you and one scene and i have to
draw the background with the character
on it
and all the movement of the character
just
rough very rough okay very rough and
also if there is a
camera works i have to add it right and
uh
all put the timing of this cut oh wow
okay
so it's basically like it's it's
basically like the storyboard but just
a bit more refine
you see the character what movement he
will do
just like when you see like those
outline sketches yeah yeah
like that and but you don't need to push
it
the most so you have to watch the
drawings
although you have to know a bit of all
the what the character is
the armor exactly and
when you finish that you so you send it
back to the director the
director will check it at some
correction or the arm is a too low more
higher
the expression not sad more angry
and after those corrections by the
director it will go to the
sakan so sakuga kantoku is mean the
animation director okay okay and the
animation director
will put it your drawings more in model
so if you have see good drawing
it's because the sak can have put all
his gut on it
because the second in one episode there
is at least one or two
and here they have to check the 150 cuts
oh wow so so they basically make sure
that the characters kind of look the
same
yeah and consistent each in fact the
animators just uh draw a
rough diamond and if this diamond is
good quality
after the second can polish it right
right right right
so like so like how many like say for
like mikey academy like an episode of my
hair academy like how many
different animators would be working on
like one episode for instance like
individual anime uh
i think uh maybe on average an average
uh
uh at least 10 animators could be good
if you but
uh you can see on the credits right
right how many animators gengar
can get right uh how many animators
sometimes you have a 15 animators
or sometimes you have what it's called
one man army
just one guy one guy wow
have you ever done that no no no
actually i'm just a baby man
i was gonna say like how much of a
machine do you have to be to do the saga
of
an entire 24 minute episode yeah and the
dusk
guys are coral monsters oh that's
just like red like just destroyed their
wrists are just like this thing
they're very very fast in
like you see this is a japanese
animation when you see a
veteran animator who show you there's
one guy doing it all
it's like it's like that scene from
hunter hunter where the guy returns from
like
being up in the mountains for like 10
years or something
just returns and it just shows everyone
how it's done
and everyone becomes its disciples
something would take me
like one day you can do it in one hour
oh my god wow yes some people have too
much talent
because he has also me i'm just i'm
31 yeah right and guy my senpai
it's like 31 years of experience in
animation
oh my god now that's why and jim's a
baby so five years in the anime industry
is like
nothing it's nothing wow oh my god
we'll have you back on in 20 years